luces máquinas tragaperras apuestas
póker blackjack en casi seguro que
cuando escuchamos estos términos nuestra
mente se desplace automáticamente hasta
el script de las negativas
la ciudad de los excesos la ciudad que
muchos consideran como la capital del
juego verdad amigos es error porque la
verdadera capital mundial del juego no
es las vegas sino mejor
macao es una ciudad autónoma situada en
el sur de china muy cerca de hong kong
de hecho están tan cerca que la forma
más habitual de llegar a macao es yendo
en los ferrys que van a toda velocidad
que conectan estas dos ciudades en poco
más de una hora precisamente es así como
he a macao hace unos meses desde hong
kong
si hubiera sabido que iba a hacer este
vídeo hoy probablemente habría hecho
fotos mejores bien cuando llegas a macao
te encuentras con una ciudad bastante
curiosa por un lado es un pedacito de
portugal dentro del trópico y vibrante
sudeste asiático por otro es un lugar
donde es fácil encontrar rascacielos y
llamativas construcciones modernas la
perspectiva de la ciudad por ejemplo
está dominada por un enorme rascacielos
con cristales de colores que tienen la
forma de la flor de loto el casino gran
lisboa
y sobre todo es una ciudad desordenada
un tanto destartalada y llena de
callejuelas macao fue la última colonia
europea en alza continental y lo fue
prácticamente hasta antes de ayer
durante siglos fue parte de portugal y a
finales de 1999 se integró en china lo
hizo como una región administrativa
especial donde rige el modelo de un país
dos sistemas el mismo que tiene hong
kong estas dos ciudades a pesar de ser
partes de china mantienen aunque con
alguna limitación sus propias leyes
a tribunales monedas e instituciones
políticas en la práctica funcionan como
países diferentes en esta región incluso
el portugués es lengua oficial
más que sentimental ahora bien marcado
más que una ciudad es una especie de
parque temático del juego que cada año
recibe a más de 30 millones de turistas
si tal como lo escucháis este minúsculo
trozo de tierra es uno de los lugares
más visitados del mundo la razón es el
único lugar de china donde se permite el
juego
y en parte en gracias a ello desde que
se separó de portugal y hasta 2014 esta
ciudad región vivió uno de los procesos
de crecimiento económico más rápidos de
la historia en poco más de diez años su
pib se multiplicó por más de pie pasando
de cinco mil millones a más de 55.000
millones de dólares en este vertiginoso
proceso hay un momento clave el año 2002
cuando el gobierno autónomo liberal hizo
la industria del juego en ese momento
las grandes multinacionales del sector
se abalanzaron sobre ella transformando
su identidad para siempre en la cultura
asiática el juego es aceptado como forma
de entretenimiento y ese es un detonante
para el éxito que se ve aquí en hoy es
conocida como las vegas' china por su
altísima concentración de casinos pero
la verdad este es un calificativo casi
ridículo porque macao amigos de visual
política es la capital mundial del juego
sus más de 40 casinos facturaron el
pasado año la escandalosa cifra de 29
mil millones de dólares
casi cinco veces más que las vegas y
sabéis que en su punto álgido en 2013
makau consiguió batir por más de siete
los ingresos por juegos de azar de las
vegas' alcanzando atentos la cervera de
45.000 millones de dólares que es casi
tanto como lo que ingresa españa con
todo el turismo extranjero es para
quedarse boquiabierto juego luces
tiendas de lujo y más luces esa es cada
vez más la identidad de esta ciudad los
casinos de macao ya lo sabéis a partir
de ahora cada vez que penséis en una
máquina tragaperras en una mesa de póker
o de blackjack no penséis en montecarlo
ni en las vegas' pensar en macao tan
sólo en los últimos doce meses se han
abierto tres nuevos macro casinos con
inversiones milmillonarias a finales de
2015 se puso en marcha el estudios y un
complejo ambientado en hollywood y para
cuya inauguración se grabó el
cortometraje más caro de la historia con
un presupuesto de 70 millones de dólares
fue dirigido nada menos por martin
scorsese y sus protagonistas fueron
robert
leonardo dicaprio brad pitt
d
bueno
esa es una inauguración y lo demás son
tonterías un poco más cerca en agosto de
2016 abrió sus puertas el wing palace un
coloso de lujo con más de 1.700
habitaciones que le ha costado a sus
promotores nada menos que 4 mil 200
millones de dólares
el más reciente de todos el último en
abrir ha sido de parís ya la nueva joya
del imperio de las vegas sands la
empresa que quiso construir euroligas en
madrid os acordáis
pero
en este caso el complejo es casi una
ciudad tiene tres mil habitaciones un
parque de agua e incluso su propio
torrijos
y las aperturas continúan y el siguiente
será presta atención de hacer quin el
complejo de megalujo más caro del mundo
cada una de las habitaciones costará
entre 50.000 y 100.000 dólares por noche
no no me he vuelto loco sus huéspedes
tendrán incluso 30 rolls royce phantom a
su disposición aunque con esos precios
casi que se los podían hasta regalar
junto a todas estas incorporaciones los
casinos más míticos de macao son el
galaxy el gran lisboa el city of dreams
el wing el venetian el mgm y muchos más
a este paso el strip de las vegas nos
resultar casi como una cosa de
principiantes pero falto de beneficios
en macao más del 80% de los ingresos
gubernamentales proceden de los casinos
y la cantidad de dinero que el gobierno
obtiene es tan elevada que cada año
tienen un superávit enormes aquí no
saben lo que es el déficit público y por
supuesto como ya os podéis imaginar los
impuestos son bajos en este caso la
pregunta es clara qué hace el gobierno
con todos esos superávit que obtiene
cada año pues bien una parte lo ahorro
otra [ __ ] en infraestructuras y
capital y una tercera parte atentos la
reparte como dividendos a todos los
residentes de la ciudad como lo
escucháis desde 2008 todos los
habitantes de esta ciudad reciben una
parte de los beneficios que el gobierno
tiene de los casinos este año por
ejemplo la cantidad ha sido de más de
mil dólares por ciudadano es decir una
familia de cuatro personas por ejemplo
recibe cada mes un cheque del gobierno
por casi 400 euros nuestra más verdad y
los beneficios para los ciudadanos no
terminan aquí casi una cuarta parte de
los empleos dependen de la industria de
los casinos bajos impuestos trabajo y
encima dividendos ahora bien no todo es
color de rosas
e
crisis en macau de la inmensa mayoría de
los turistas de macao dos terceras
partes proceden de la china continental
con lo que la economía de esta región
autónoma está íntimamente ligada a la
del gigante asiático por si fuese poco
xi jinping el presidente china puso en
marcha una guerra contra la corrupción
entre los funcionarios en 2015 y es
entonces cuando la economía de la ciudad
se vino abajo
algunos de estos jugadores importantes
son funcionarios del gobierno chino a
quienes por ley les está prohibido
entrar a los casinos y mucho más jugar
en tan solo un año los ingresos del
juego se exploraron un 40% en la
economía de la ciudad perdió más del 20
por ciento de su pib casi tanto como
grecia desde 2008 en sólo un año los
funcionarios corruptos chinos habían
cogido afición a los casinos de esta
ciudad aquí podían gastar el dinero con
relativa libertad pasar temporadas a
cuerpo de rey e incluso con un poco de
suerte blanquear parte de sus nuevas
fortunas
la economía depende de la industria de
casinos que representa el 80 por ciento
de los ingresos del gobierno y ha tenido
dificultades para adaptarse a la campaña
contra la corrupción lanzada por pekín
en 2014 si no es que todo el sector
dependiente de ellos ni mucho menos pero
entre la desaceleración económica y los
nuevos controles establecidos por el
gobierno china muchos de los bills que
acudían a macao han dejado de hacerlo al
menos por una temporada
a la mitad de la economía de macao
depende directamente de los casinos de
todas formas gracias a la gran
acumulación de capital per cápita al
buen estado de las finanzas públicas y
las ventajas de ser un clúster turístico
tan importante los efectos
socioeconómicos han sido limitados el
gobierno mantiene un holgado superávit
la tasa de paro es de apenas el 1,8 por
ciento y los ingresos de las familias no
se han resentido a diferencia de grecia
macao han hecho los deberes eso sí ahora
tal y como dijo xi jinping en su última
visita a la ciudad
toca diversificarse y el gobierno ya ha
presentado un plan al respecto
mccabe apostará en los próximos años por
impulsar el turismo de familias el de
salud el sector financiero y el
tecnológico las autoridades esperan así
reducir la exposición de la economía a
una actividad tan volátil como el juego
especialmente ante los pronósticos del
fondo monetario internacional que prevén
una contracción de las finanzas chinas
de un 7 con 2 por ciento la actividad
económica ya comenzaba a repuntar y si
se cumplen los planes del gobierno en
unos años más
puede llegar a convertirse en una
especie de mónaco del siglo 21 el error
de la ciudad voy a apostar por solo un
sector y no por facilitar la creación de
empresas y la atracción de inversiones
con independencia del sector al que
perteneciesen algo que de forma bastante
más grave también ha ocurrido en
atlantic city pero de eso hablaremos
otro día si os ha parecido el caso de
macao si queréis que sigamos hablando de
asia no olvidéis darle a like a este
vídeo para hacérnoslo saber y si aún no
estáis suscritos al canal leñe haciendo
ahora pulsando este botón y recibiréis
nuestros nuevos vídeos al instante un
saludo y hasta la próxima
los encargados vigilan a los jefes de
mesa los jefes de planta vigilan a los
encargados los managers vigilan a los
jefes de plancha
el gerente del casino vigila a los
managers yo vigilo al gerente del casino
y el ojo de la cámara los vigila a todos
nosotros